as i said you want to break these down
at this level probably once a month
okay or maybe every 200 to 250 hours
okay the guides and the power feeders as
i said usually every couple weeks or
maybe 80 to 100 hours okay
so to get to the guides guys you're
going to use your guide wrench okay
you don't really need any other tools
okay your guide wrench takes out both
the upper and lower guide and the c is
actually for the common guy we're going
to get to that when we take the heads
completely apart
okay u is for the upper d's for the
lower okay for some reason um
asians are up and down it's always up
and down i don't know why they say that
instead of upper and lower
it's never lower it's always down so
anyways the upper flush cut guys
comes off by spinning out the housing
that holds it in place okay that just
spins off
splash guard then comes off
the flush cup just falls off guys
usually it'll stay in place though if
you don't do anything tap on it it might
fall out
there's an o-ring that sits on the inner
lip you want to make sure that stays in
place or it doesn't get lost
okay
after that comes off guys you got your
jet nozzle and that pulls straight down
comes off it's just got an o-ring that
kind of rolls over the
metal section right there just kind of
rolls over it stays in place
once that comes off you can see the
upper guide hanging down okay right
there
okay so we're going to use the u and the
guide wrench
going to get on the flat section of the
guide
and we're going to spin it out
so here's what the upper guide looks
like
it is marked
basically you can see it says zero two
five so point two five millimeter
um and basically
when you clean it guys
all right
as i said the guides usually an
ultrasonic cleaner works very well on
here the agitation process it
kind of shakes all that crap out of the
guide and then you know it cleans it up
okay i try to tell people don't use any
uh
extremely aggressive solvents on the
guides okay like we're talking about
using that enviroplane you don't really
want to use that on the guys themselves
the diamond in here is actually held in
by like an adhesive
and uh if you use anything too terribly
aggressive and leave it in there a long
time
then it can actually break the adhesive
down and the guide the diamond gets
loose in the guide and then the guides
are no good anymore i want to lack yours
so usually on the guides i use like an
alkaline cleaner or something like that
something that's almost just like soap
simple green works pretty well as well
you can just dilute that with a little
bit of water that's fine
okay
you can use the acid cleaner to an
extent the enviroclean but if you put it
in the ultrasonic cleaner like a minute
or two tops okay and then you got to
make sure you rinse it really really
well
okay now matt was saying that that the
jewelry cleaner that comes in the
jewelry cleaners is fine if you buy a
jewelry that's fine just that's like an
alkaline cleaner that's what that is oh
man that's not aggressive at all no
um
as i said one for pearls because they
have another solution that comes with it
usually that's even finer but yeah i'm
sure it's fine for no it's that's
totally fine um as i said if you do use
the enviro clean guys just
don't leave it in there very long see
the problem is somebody throws the
guides in there because they're doing
maintenance on a machine
they turn the assault the ultrasonic
cleaner on there and then they forget
about them and they sit in there eight
hours and then they ruin the guides so
if you use something very mild and if
that happens no big deal okay
when you fit this thing clean guys to
check it okay what i always do is i take
the wire
and i push it through the guide and make
sure that it doesn't have any
obstructions okay it goes through nice
and smooth
i also check the cross hole okay there's
a cross hole that goes through the guide
for aeration
okay the wire should go through that
cross hole as well
my eyes aren't quite as good as they
used to be because so basically the wire
goes through the cross hole everybody
sees that okay lower one is going to be
the same way
okay the lower guide guys can be
accessed by spinning the guide excuse me
the flush cut housing out
flush cup comes off
wave washer comes off okay that's where
the lower flush cup gets its spring
push it down it compresses that wave
washer okay
once you get to that you got the lower
guy okay you're going to use the d for
down spin the lower guide out
okay technically guys you can thread the
lower and the upper and the upper and
lower but i mean if you look at them you
can tell that you know this one's
supposed to be the lower because it's
got
basically an inlet that the wire would
go in if you put this one in lower
the wire would never make it in there
okay because it's got just a you know
straight flat top right wire never make
it in there but technically the threads
are the same so yeah you could mix them
up
but you know
lower one guys same deal pass the wire
through the guide
and also through the cross hole
now the power feeders guys
are going to be accessed by
opening this throw lever
okay the power feeders can be accessed
without having to take anything else
apart okay so
basically if we just remove the power
feeders and don't touch the guides we
don't have to realign the wire because
the guides are still in the same
original location
okay the power feeders guys once you
open up the throw lever that takes the
pressure off of the power feeder
and basically you can slide it out
is what the power feeder looks like okay
so it's just a flat bar carbide you guys
can see there's some scale on it it's
kind of dirty
okay
generally anytime i take and actually
index these i also clean them a little
bit so i take a little bit of scotch
brite
must come right off you clean it a
little bit okay
grooves don't but the scale does
okay
you'd also don't want to get a whole
bunch of scale built up on here because
that sometimes interferes with the
thread cycle because the wire's kind of
got to pass by
at least the lower power feeder the
upper one kind of pushes out of the way
but the lower one it's got to kind of go
by so
you guys can all see the groove right
there
okay
so when you're actually indexing these
power feeders guys
after you clean them up
you got your power feeder adjustment
tool okay which is located right here
all right
this thing's a little bit hokey but it
works okay
so
what you do is they all they both burn
on the back side guys all right
so starting on the back side you go from
right to left
okay you got one side says upper one
side it says lower okay so when you're
starting this off
you're gonna push this thing in here
until
you see the numbers on here you got 1
through 12 you're going to line the one
up with the side of the head right there
okay then you lock it down
okay when it comes time to index them
you push it to the two lock it down then
three and then four then five six all
the way to twelve
okay
once you've gone to twelve you go to the
other side and you go thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen all the way to twenty
four
okay once you've gone 24 times take it
out flip it around 112 12 24 again you
got 48 index points
okay
now both power feeders should always be
on the same number guys okay i get a
little frustrated a lot of times people
just take the damn thing and move it and
they don't check where they're actually
at they just move it to an arbitrary
spot so they got a fresh spot and that's
it okay you start burning randomly all
over the place and you don't know where
you're at
okay so try and keep it actually keep
track of it on each one of them now
technically you can measure it guys okay
if i take this thing out of here this is
the way it was in okay and i flip it
around lay it on top okay you can see
the groove is lined up exactly with the
one
ah
okay i can check and see where the
grooves are then it would be two three
four all the way to twelve
okay now basically
it goes from the center out and then the
center out the other way it doesn't go
from one side all the way across that's
why the first groove is in the center
okay
so i'm just gonna basically set this
thing up back on the one i'm gonna
tighten up the throw lever just a little
bit so right there i'm on the one and
i'm going to tighten it up and that's it
okay
the lower one guys
you're not going to line it up with the
edge of the head right here you're going
to line it up with the edge of these
little ears sticking out
okay
so on the lower
okay you can see that it's at the one on
the right side there
at the edge of the ear
okay then you'll go one through three
all the way to 12
and you'll go 13 14 to 24 same thing
flip it around go 112 124 again
okay
so if you line it up with the side of
the head instead of the ear itself
you'll push the thing out of the head
before it gets to 12.
so same thing if i pull out the lower
okay i can check it on the lower i lay
it up top i can see there's the groove
on the one
okay
somebody's already kind of moved this
thing around a few times but these other
grooves are just like almost surface
grooves
not really any type of a burn in there
spell
you know
mark what match you're on
there's not really anywhere on the
controller to mark what notch you're on
um
but if you take and check it before you
pull it out then you can tell and you'll
know okay so when you go into the
maintenance screen as i said you have
your timer for your power feeders once
that hits 80 hours
you know you're ready to index them you
move to the next notch you reset the
elapse and then you're in good shape